All right.
Hello everyone and thank you for coming today.
Am pleased that you've joined us for a Dr. Alexander Todorov.
Discussion of his new book face value,
the irresistible influence.
Uh,
first impressions.
The book discusses Dr [inaudible] Research at the social perception lab at
Princeton as well as others in his field into how our minds recognize and
interpret faces,
uh,
in extremely short periods of time and how those interpretations color our
behavior often an inefficient,
inaccurate,
and somewhat disturbing ways.
Please join me in welcoming to the stage Dr. Alexander Todorov.
[inaudible]
well first,
thank you all for coming.
Thank you Tim.
With too,
I want to start first with the history of physionomy and this is the pseudo
science of reading character from faces.
Uh,
[inaudible] has a very long history with the first documents dating back
tourists totals time,
but it really,
it really got extremely popular dance of the 18th century.
And what you see here is probably the cover of the first Swiss best seller.
It was threatened by Johan Casper lovetre.
It was a four volume work on,
uh,
physionomy and was extremely,
extremely popular in Europe.
And none other than God to help him edit the first volume.
Some of the best two illustrators of the day worked on the book and it was
really phenomenally successful.
Um,
one interesting anecdote is that Darwin almost missed his chance to take the
bigger we ash.
And this is the west,
which enabled him to make his observational in the base of his evolutionary
theory and the count of his nose because the captain of the ship then sell to a
big fan of flava her.
And he didn't believe that person would,
such a nose would possess efficient energy and determination for the we ash.
Luckily for science,
Darwin made it,
uh,
and he nodded and his autobiography,
but I think he was afterwards well satisfied that my nose had spoken falsely.
Uh,
and this is what the gentleman's magazine was a very popular publication,
uh,
in London.
And this is part of the obituary of flood water in Switzerland,
in Germany,
in France,
even in Great Britain,
all the world became passionate admirers of the physio conomical sense of
flutter and the obituary goal song to compare his,
the popular care of his books with the popularity of the Bible.
Perhaps a bit of an exaggeration,
but it gives you an idea of how
influential these ideas.
So we may poke fun at physionomy lists,
but it sounds sense we are all knife is your honor.
We do form instantaneously impressions and react.
And this impressions,
let me start with a few demonstrations.
He imagine that you're walking into a party and this are the first two people.
You see how many people would approach the person on the left.
Okay.
I don't even need to ask how many people were project a person on the right.
So it's the clear majority.
Actually this faces were not generated by an artist,
but I buy brought empirical forest.
This is actually a mathematical model and I'll tell her later how we construct
those,
which captures the consensus in impressions of extroversion and introversion.
So the,
the phase that most of you are willing to approach is the prototypical
extroverted face.
Here's another demonstration with real images.
Imagine the decent twins,
the evil one and the good one who is more likely to be the evil one.
It's another easy one.
Uh,
the face on the right.
Why?
Because it can actually generate a model of criminal appearance,
what people think a typical criminal looks like.
And in this case you apply the model to the face and southern and the face
becomes a little bit more masculine and people are more willing to pass this
kind of judgements based just on appearance.
Notice that you do have to think to form this impression.
So you didn't pawn the,
well,
let me see.
Should I go with the person the right should I go with the person that left?
It's something that the moment you see the images,
you know what seems like the right response.
Um,
and we can actually test how quickly this impressions of form we've done,
uh,
many stories and many other labs could followed by.
You can present a face for extremely brief amount of time and then you put
something which we called perceptual mass,
kind of to raise it from your consciousness.
And then we look at what is the minimal exposure you need to see a face to form
an impressions.
And in fact even about 15 milliseconds gives you enough time to make up your
mind and essentially,
or judge Munson,
no different whatsoever from your judgments when you have fun,
limited time.
If you have seen the face for about hundred 10 6,070 milliseconds.
So literally this is a single glance impressions because I movement takes about
200,
250 milliseconds.
So as long as you can see the face,
it's not some kind of a gigantic face,
you make up your mind fairly rapidly.
Yeah.
This impression.
So not only,
okay,
immediate and compelling,
they also consequential.
It's actually the very first study that made me interested in studying first
impressions.
We are looking at where the snap judgments of running for the u s Senate in this
particular case.
Uh,
what predict the electoral success.
And it turns out that if you aggregate across a relatively small sample of
participants about 40,
who have no idea who they are judging,
we can pick up about 70% of,
uh,
the outcomes of the election.
So if you imagine about a hundred Senate races,
we can predict about 70.
And again,
you need very little time.
He is a demo.
This was probably about 250 millisecond presentation.
You can see it again,
if you're a participant in our lab studies,
and again,
we can predict,
uh,
even after very brief,
presentation,
these judgments do justice well.
In fact,
the only conditions in which we don't do very well if you tell participants,
think carefully and make a good judgment.
And what this does is essentially introduces noise in their judgments.
Um,
there's been a lots of international replications.
This is one,
uh,
that we did in my home country,
Bulgaria,
where I grew up and where we were.
And it's,
this is the last presidential elections.
And they're kind of interesting because there's a low bar to get into the
elections.
And in this particular case,
we have Americans judging Bulgarian candidates for president.
So clearly they have no idea who they are.
And you can see there's a very nice linear relationship between how competent
they look to Americans and the margin of victory.
Sadly,
the bearded men in the lower left corner was one of my professor at South
University.
So he can see he didn't do well.
This many,
many other demonstrations about the effects of first impressions.
And I cover many of them in the book.
For example,
in terms of economic transactions,
you can,
uh,
create a careful experiments where you think you're interacting with three old
people.
But in fact you interact a king with faces that the manipulator to appear more
or less trustworthy.
And even when you have good information about their past behavior,
people are more willing to invest in so called trustworthy looking people.
What is going on here?
Well,
when we make decisions,
especially when we are busy and we're busy,
most of the time we rely on heuristics.
We rely on hunches.
And in fact,
when it comes to strangers,
the easiest heuristics is sour.
First impression,
you might be wondering,
for example,
to get back to the politicians example.
So who are those voters who were really,
I mean,
first of all,
we collect judgments from students who are certainly not representative of the
people who end up voting.
And in fact follow up with,
uh,
by political scientists has shown that it's a particular group of voters who
gets to be influenced by appearance.
These are the people who know next to nothing about politics.
So if you divide them by their political knowledge,
the more you know,
the less of an effect.
And the people who know most this zero effect of appearance and their decisions.
But the people who know very little,
and I'm talking about people who cannot name the vice president,
they influence and their particular influence if they watch a lot of TV.
So obviously need to be exposed to the candidate to form an impressions.
So what they're doing,
they're looking for the right information,
competence,
but in the wrong place appearance because it is easy.
Okay,
so physiology and Miss God,
a few things,
right?
Okay.
One faceless immediately capture our attention.
In fact,
even if you look at a scene and there's faces,
even if I tell her,
don't look at the face,
he can't help it.
In fact,
faces attract our attention.
There's snow,
the object that the trucks our attention so rapidly.
Moreover,
this attention is a company by all kinds of attributions of flux and dislikes.
And you might be completely wrong about it,
uh,
for emotional and mental states and have character attributions and essay just
showed you this.
Attributions are not,
are not inconsequential,
they do matter.
Okay?
And so we,
we actually have known about the consequences of first impressions in psychology
for a few decades now.
But the question is,
well,
what gives rise to this particular impressions?
And that's what I've been studying for the last seven or eight years.
Okay.
And the question that is,
what is it in the face that makes me think that the face of truss work here or
dominant or competent or whatever.
And one way to try to figure this out is the standard way where you can start
manipulating facial features and say,
well let me,
I can have faces that had a smile or they don't smile.
And then I can see to what extent the presence of a smile affects the,
your impression.
This is actually in when it comes to visual perceptions,
typically artists of the first who have started these kinds of questions do or
not with the same kinds of methods,
but this is an illustration from a 19th century book by Alexander Cuisines,
a British painter.
And he has uh,
uh,
had the book on the,
what is the ideal beauty and he was trying to discount the ideal beauty and he
dealt with the slight alterations of some of the facial features.
You can have 12 character beauties and then so he will manipulate different
kinds of eyebrows,
noses,
mouth and so on.
And in many ways it's not very different than what he was doing as an
experimental psychologist.
The problem with this approach is that you run very quickly out of steam because
the space of possible hypothesis infinity,
a large,
just 10 binary features give you over thousand combinations.
So you need to construct an experiment in which you have lots of lots of,
uh,
combinations just to be more specific.
If cousins were proper experimental psychologist,
he noticed that he's working with very simple drawings,
right?
He is working with profile drawings and he's uh,
uh,
working with relatively few variations for different kinds of foreheads,
12 different kinds of noses.
Now,
if he were to be a real experimental scientists,
he should have combined all of these combinations and then he would have had
about 300,000 drawings just to figure out what matters in terms of what people
find beautiful.
So it is,
uh,
a task that is not easy and there are lots of complex interactions.
Uh,
typically when we describe face perception,
we describe it this holistic,
which means that the meaning of a single feature,
what you see can change in the context of father futures.
And there are lots of interesting demonstrations in the book.
This is there isn't there about 160 illustrations because it's much easier to
explain this kind of phenomena by showing you an image than to describe it
verbally.
But take a look at this two faces,
it should be easy.
Can you see how the face on the left is smiling?
But it is an illusion.
The ice actually completely identical.
The difference is that in the image on the left,
there's this smile that is inserted and the smile in the face makes you see the
eyes are smiling.
So there are lots of fascinating demonstrations of a perceptual illusions with
faces.
So how do we go about,
uh,
figuring cow?
What is the basis of different stereotypes?
Impression stereotypes without manipulating features.
Here's one way.
Uh,
we can simply take the same face.
In this particular case,
it's actually the same face in the upper two images.
You only differences with you.
It kind of impose different kinds of visual noise.
Okay?
It's a technique that comes from psychophysics.
Now imagine that if your subject in this kind of study,
you will see a few hundred trials in which you have two faces and you have to
say,
well,
which one looks more trustworthy?
And maybe we go to the one on the left or to the right.
If you do this few hundred times
and then I average all of the trials in which you say,
this face looks
more trustworthy to me,
then I actually extract what's in your mind,
what,
what is it that you see in your mind?
This trustworthy,
not as the dis construct it entirely from visual noise really.
And from your response bias,
here's the noise,
slightly distorts the image and then we can capture systematic biases if you do
it sufficient number of times.
And this is what it looks like.
This is the untrustworthy face.
It can see it looks kind of angry and threatening.
This is the trustworthy face with a slight smile and much,
much more feminine.
Uh,
this is the dominant face and this is the submissive face.
And you can do this with any kinds of category where there's some kind of
agreement.
Obviously,
if I show this to a different group of participants,
they agree with this initial categorizations,
we can actually even do better by building models of first impressions.
And you already saw some examples in the beginning of the talk.
And for to do this all we need to do a statistical model in which each face is
just a set of numbers and you don't need to know the details,
but it starts from a laser scanning of real people,
their face in three d and then you should do different kinds of statistical
technique.
You can extract uh,
uh,
some numerical representation of faces.
And the Nice thing is now that I can generate as many faces as they want and
each face is completely determined in this pace.
Now this is super convenient because now if I have participants form impressions
of the faces,
I have one set of numbers,
the impressions and the set of numbers that describe where the faces send this
statistical space.
And it's kind of foremost trivial now to visualize,
to build a model of the things that change in the face and drive a particular
impression.
That is if people agree.
And the one difference that I've noticed between computer scientists,
and I bet they're many computer scientists,
can psychologist,
he's a computer scientist.
You can immediately take the data and built a model.
But if you're a psychologist,
the first thing you want to find out is that people agree because if they don't,
he essentially fitting nice 80 need to make sure that there's some kind of
consensus.
So again,
if you're a participant in this study,
as you can see,
one of these synthetic faces,
you can rate it on a scale.
Let's say one to nine how trustworthy are,
how dominant it appears to you to have another one.
And the only medical ratings might be different.
But they bet that for most people,
the second phase and the lower right corner will appear more dominant and less
trustworthy than the first phase.
And here's your trustworthiness model.
This is the running classwork in a scoring standard units.
Okay?
So this is some tally notice that we don't manipulate anything APRIORI.
What we'll do is to randomly generate faces where the future's a very randomly.
We ask subjects to make judgments.
And to the extent that they agree,
the model captures this kind of agreement.
And what has what has happening cleared,
zoom in on some of the changes.
Now we are just keeping the texture of the face,
the skin surface and everything constant and we are changing the shape.
Well what happens,
many things happen.
But one of the things that certainly pops out is emergence of emotional
expressions.
Although we didn't manipulate emotional expressions at all.
So this tells you,
well one of the inputs to this kind of impression says your emotional
expression,
and it doesn't have to be explicit.
It could be very subtle,
but people will pick up on this.
We can do the same on the negative fant and again,
you have emotional expressions,
but they're kind of negative.
The face looks much more disgruntled.
Uh,
we can do this money modeling not only the shape but also the reflectance in the
movie too.
You're right,
the surface texture of the face and you can see that the face becomes much more
feminine and now much more masculine when it turns into so called caught on,
caught on word,
you're looking face again.
It can zoom in and
as you can see,
the face becomes much more feminine.
She had the shape of the face is identical,
but the only thing that we are manipulating kids,
the surface texture.
And similarly if a,
uh,
increase the face is in the directions of untrustworthiness,
you get a much more masculine face.
And He,
I can create a caricature because I can exaggerate this as much as I want.
And here's your caricatures son untrustworthy.
And I transferred to looking face,
so trustworthy to looking face.
It's kind of a woman,
which Chris seems to be saying.
I'm so happy to see you and the untrustworthy faces,
this kind of disgruntled,
uh,
strong looking guy.
We can do this for any other judgment.
He is dominance.
Dominance is really about extreme masculinity.
And now we can see on the other side of the face becomes solid,
acquires this baby faced features very large for her plow choice,
things that,
so now we can draw inferences about the things that go into this sorts of
impressions.
And again,
here's your caricatures of a extremely dominant Anna.
Extremely submissive phase.
So as you can see they all have faced for leader.
You can use different kinds of morphing methods.
This was done in the UK where they started with a few thousand pictures of
people from the Internet and you can create,
isolate the faces at the perceived this list truss work you're most trusts.
Work can create a morphing continuum and just like in our studies,
gender changes,
expression changes.
Something that we didn't see.
H is obviously also important and you can do the same thing for dominance in any
other.
You might be
wondering quiet this particular too they mentioned,
so suppose to many others.
It turns out that most social impressions,
most social judgements are highly correlated.
10.
You can really summarize most of them with this tool judgements.
One is trustworthiness,
which is really about positivity and negativity.
Can Ya'll days dominance and you can think of trustworthiness is sort of your
impression of trustworthiness is indicating.
Trying to figure out whether the person has good or bad intentions here and now
and of dominance says whether the person is capable of fucking on this,
uh,
impressions.
But in general we can do this for any kinds of impressions.
We've done it for dozens of them and the many distractions of the book.
He is my favorite extroversion,
which you already saw demonstrations.
Okay.
However,
I'm before I moved to the third part and again,
I don't have time to go over this.
Then many,
many other determinants of Im impressions that are not simply reducible to
facial features.
Uh,
you can think of all of this is what's this in the eye of the beholder?
What do you see as the typical phase is very important and that naturally varies
depending on in what kind of culture you have grown up or where you live.
We tend to like a typical phases and dislike atypical faces.
Face the resemblance is important.
We tend to like people who resemble people whom we already like,
self resemble a slot.
So price is important.
We tend to like people who look like us and this all idiosyncratic
contributions,
uh,
to first impressions.
Let me just give you an example of a study.
Looking at this car,
we can create this in the lab.
You can be presented with faces and you see a statement like he made an obscene
gesture at an old lady and obviously you're thinking,
well you're not even thinking kid immediately.
Just s intuitively think this is not a nice guy.
And so we can create this very rapidly to make people form associations between
particular facial image and particular kinds of positive for negative behavior.
And then you evaluate tech novel people like this guys here.
But what is the key that all of them have about 30% of the so called bad guy.
And in fact faces that the morphed with faces you already learned to dislike
because of their past behavior you tend to dislike.
And the other way around if they were to be more fit positive faces.
So one thing we can say is that in the absence of good information about other
people,
first impressions,
our best attempt to figure out the intentions here now and from all of this
work,
we can say that,
that construct it from things that typically have a meaningful QC in the social
world,
masculinity,
femininity,
and all of our agenda expectation that comes with it.
Facial maturity,
emotional expressions,
cultural typicality,
resemblance to familiar others and so on.
But the big question after all of this as well,
are those first impressions really accurate?
In fact,
if they were accurate,
it's not a big deal that they influence important social decisions.
But what is really the evidence that this first impressions are accurate
in some very interesting way.
And this is still a large extent,
what prompted me to write the book is there has been a revival of physionomy say
ds in modern days.
I mean he is a,
uh,
this was from the front page of the New York Times,
the,
in this case,
this was Milwaukee Bucks of basketball team when they had this face reader to
tell them who would be a good prospect or not.
And it's much worse than that face.
Ception is a facial personality profiling technology company.
It's an Israeli startup,
which is actually doing physionomy all staff is generic machine learning
methods.
This a paper that came out a few months ago by two computer scientists in China,
uh,
where they claim that you can predict with 90% accuracy whether a person is
claiming or not.
This actually prompted a blesser Guayaki Arcas if you guys know him,
he hits your vision group,
can Saulteaux.
Uh,
I caught a paper with him and Mech Richard's,
uh,
which we,
published on medium.com,
which was a kind of a,
our view of all of the things that go wrong with this kind of research and why
he should be really skeptical about this kinds of results.
But before I get into the issues and accuracy,
let me introduce the,
uh,
again,
the story with the little bit of history because history is extremely relevant
and the same blunders that have been committed,
you know,
150 years ago of being committed today.
So 19th century was to hey their physionomy,
uh,
to Zara,
Alon Brazo,
uh,
is,
wrote a lots of books,
case kind of founder of criminal anthropologists.
So he wrote lots of books.
The criminal man,
the criminal woman and his theories were very popular in Europe.
In fact,
it wasn't just like populate in the sense of they're popular,
but they were sent [inaudible] congress is all over Europe that were attended by
a governmental bureaucrats,
lawyers,
scientists,
and so on and so on.
And had a specific Gary that criminals for this kind of sub humans.
And Moreover,
you can read this up,
humanist from their appearance.
Francis Galton who is a fascinating character and I have Roy write extensively
about him in the first chapter in,
in subsequent chapter,
uh,
he would have been celebrated this one of the greatest scientists of 19th
century if it were not his obsession with eugenics.
Heredity energetics is the father,
the father of eugenics.
And uh,
he invented the composite photography,
which was a method of essentially morphing but pre digital era morphing where
you would super impose negatives of different photographs to find the average
and image.
And his first objective was to discover the criminal type or the criminal type
looks like,
uh,
and have a look [inaudible] who was a progressive,
intellectual in the UK.
He compare to the influence of Lombroso to the influence of Darwin.
It was a big deal.
This is like a,
an the aunt of 19th century.
So he sake and 90,
far five book,
the Criminal Ellis included drawings of criminal faces,
Julius threat,
how they,
how atypical there.
Okay.
This was like,
here's the illustration of proof that loan process,
right?
And in fact,
if you look at the faces,
they do look very weird,
right?
But images,
whether they're drawn or photographs can be deeply misleading.
I mean it's like Pawling New York City to find out whether the Trump will be the
next president.
Obviously we'll get it very wrong,
right?
So this is your,
how you sample images is extremely important.
Uh,
a bias sample of individuals will lead to biased inferences.
And there was a very interesting book in the beginning of a 20th century by
Charles goring who started about,
uh,
6,000 convicted prisoners in the UK.
And then it all kinds of statistics to Tessalon Brazos theory if he found zero
evidence in favor of process theory.
But he opens this book with this two images,
the image on your left,
he just drew a random sample of 30 prisoners and then super impose them to
create the average image.
And Yeah,
that was essentially the superimposed images have the restrictions from Harwell
Kelleys and in fact,
this face looks weird as a goring.
Put it.
On examination of this contrast,
it outlines,
shows most strikingly the difference between criminal types.
It's registered by the mechanical precision of a camera and Svu by the
imagination of fun,
enthusiastic.
But then critical observer,
she put it really nicely.
Um,
there's even a bigger problem and this is something that many of us,
including many people who study face perceptions don't think much about it.
A bias sample.
A few images of the same person will results in biased impressions.
Different images of the same person often result in very different impressions.
We can do this.
For example,
we can use some of our methods and applied to a real face just to share in this
example,
make the face more or less extroverted and they can simply use the
psychophysical technique that I described earlier.
Take the same image and make it look more or less trust 40 more or less dominant
depending what kind of parts of the image the highlighted.
This is again,
all derived empirically or you can do something that a newspaper editors have
been doing for many years and many people doing it.
You can use different images.
So if I ask you,
who do you like more on the top two faces?
Most people go with the face on the left.
If I ask you who do like more in the lower two faces?
Most people go with the face on the right,
but did you notice that on the right is the same person and in the leftist
another person it's the same person.
If it's somebody that you knew that would be trivial and the image activates all
of this knowledge,
but actually we are not very good when it comes to processing a fun familiar
faces.
When the face is unfamiliar we have no idea.
So you can generate.
So here's the same people,
but in the one pair of images,
one looks more attractive for more trustworthy and in the other,
the other one,
this obviously works only with unfamiliar people but First Impressions by
definitions about unfamiliar people.
So random image variation has tremendous effects and both first impressions and
person recognition when these images of unfamiliar people.
Now if I ask you to guess how many people are here,
you might be hard pressed.
I mean just kind of
because you don't know them.
They actually only tool.
I'll show relate to demonstrations with the highly familiar face and you have no
problem.
But here,
whether they shaved,
whether then shaved difference in nature,
very different and you'll be looking,
you'll be forming very different impressions.
One of these people,
if you look at the,
uh,
I don't have a pointer here,
but and the top row,
the fourth from the left to the right,
he kind of looks like a skinhead and below to the right.
She looks like this very sweet guy.
He's actually a that social psychologist who works in the UK.
But the point is that you will form very different impressions.
If I feed you a different images of these people and you wouldn't even know that
this guys did this adjust to different people.
There's no perfect correspondence between image and a person,
especially when we are not familiar with the person.
Contrast this with knowledge of familiar individuals.
There's just as much variation in this image is a in the other images,
long hair,
short hair,
beard,
no beard,
but you have no problem immediately recognizing Brad Pitt and Leonardo Dicaprio
and it doesn't matter.
This is kind of trivial.
This is important because it tells us something.
Images do not provide a magic Patrick character in some way they do for familiar
people.
Because the moment you recognize a familiar face,
this recognition comes with a lot of knowledge,
everything or most of what you know about the person,
how you feel about them.
The soul is part of your act of recognition.
There's nothing like that that happens with unfamiliar people because there's
nothing in to retrieve.
And the problem is that with our experience with familiar faces where we think
that any image,
whatever the image is,
a familiar person unlocks our knowledge of them.
We expect something similar to happen with unfamiliar people,
but it doesn't,
there are many other serious problems.
Uh,
let me just,
uh,
we'll wrap up with a couple of other issues on the accuracy.
This is a quad by,
uh,
your crystal fleet timber,
who is an absolutely fascinating character.
And I write about him a lot also in the bookie.
He was the first chair of experimental physics in Germany.
Um,
he's credited tests introducing the aphorism in the German literature influence
philosophers like Vidcon Stein.
It's just shop and Hauer a really brilliant man.
Uh,
but the reason why he was important to me,
he was the one who saw behind the writing stuff Lavato that there was nothing
there.
So he wrote this very critical say that kind of unravel the so called science
physionomically Sansa flutter and Ascii put it here.
The physionomy so horrendously mistaken in wanting to judge people whom they do
not know from sealers or porters,
that if one,
so day hits compared with their misses,
the chance nature of the game would be immediately evident.
He actually wasn't quite accurate about this.
And in the last 10 years,
many psychologists have been counting the hits and misses.
That is,
if I show her face a image of a person,
and then you have to guess their political orientation,
sexual orientation lately,
social class,
you name it,
there's a study about this.
Where'd you get it?
Better than chance.
And the surprising finding kiss.
Yeah.
People get it better than chance.
Not by much,
but better than chance.
So in this particular case,
if you have to guess whether a person is Democrat to Republican,
on average,
people get it 56% not much better than chance where chances 50 but still better
than chance.
And this has been a big deal in the literature.
We see people can do this.
So we accurate after all.
Well with one of my former students,
cursorily Vala,
who's now professor at Carnegie Mellon,
we constructed Super Dump Algorithms that use generic knowledge.
So this is called the algorithm works.
In this case,
in our task with this person sees two images and have to decide,
you know,
man or a in Democrat to Republican,
how algorithms they see the two images and they do the following.
Is it the man against a woman?
If it's a woman,
but against a man,
we guessed it.
The woman,
he said Democrat.
Is it the minority person against a majority person?
If Soviet gas,
the minority is a democrat?
Well,
let's look at the difference in age.
If it's much younger guests,
the much younger person is the Democrat and if it all fails,
we flip.
A coin obviously is not going to do very well,
but how well do they do better than humans that have all of this information,
these generic knowledge plus something in the phase that tells them the
political orientation of the person so better than chances are really feeble
criterion of judging performance.
You need to look at benchmarks.
How would you do if you just use your general knowledge,
what is like the most likely to happen in the population?
Not even look in the face.
And under many of these cases you do much better if you completely ignore the
face.
Uh,
in fact,
in many situation we will be better off if you ignore the faces completely.
Now,
don't get me wrong,
I'm not saying that the face doesn't carry useful information and I'm not saying
that first impression,
so always completely useless.
On the contrary.
They might be useful here now,
but they're very lousy guide to character if you're trying to figure what the
person is like across Thompson's times in situations,
but they do have functional value and the face is carry a lot of useful
information.
Uh,
most of the time it's about temporary states and intentions be a generally good
and picking up the emotional states of the others,
particular given the help of the context
and many other things.
Here's an example.
People have factually done controlled studies.
You have people have a normal night's sleep and then,
uh,
you take a picture of them or we let them be awake for 30 hours.
And then you take a picture under the same standard dice conditions.
And the difference is obvious,
right?
You can immediately figure out who's the sleep deprived version of the person.
Now she showed this to,
uh,
pictures,
two different groups of people.
Guess what?
The people who see the sleep deprive a version say,
well,
this guy's not very smart.
He's also probably somewhat depressed.
You know,
the,
the skin,
the skin is paler there.
Lots of things that haven't.
By the way,
all of this,
you can see this illustrations in the book.
What's happening here?
You're probably right here.
Now if you're sleep deprived,
you're not gonna do well if I ask you to do some kind of a cognitively demanding
task,
but that's not right about the person.
It's the same person and there are the effects,
which at first sites seems very surprising.
There was a very interesting gone to tutoring or study with followed twins,
thousands of twins in Denmark and uh,
looked at Dell and GVT Dennis out.
They took pictures when they were 70 or sold.
Not Surprising kid,
the best predictor,
how long you're going to lift this,
your biological age.
There's nothing that matches it,
but surprisingly 10 sounded the second best.
And in this study,
in fact,
as good as the first one is how old you look relative to your biological age.
So this,
some morphs of that.
A twin who looks younger and the twin who looks older and in fact seven,
eight,
10 years down the line,
the person who looks young is much more likely to leave.
And you say,
well,
what's going on?
Well,
faith is apart of our bodies.
What makes you look younger?
Having a better socioeconomic status,
which comes through 12th and better access to healthcare,
not having a chronic conditions,
uh,
not being chronically exposed to sun,
not some of occasions,
but being a fisherman or a bank of Pharma,
not being a smoker.
This,
all of the things that the bad for your health and they also bet for your
appearance.
So it's not surprising that different life circumstances eventually get
imprinted on your face over time.
There's nothing surprising there,
but is it about character or is it about life circumstances?
Life does leave traces and our faces,
but they need them be about character and it takes a long time to get there.
Uh,
so let me finish up.
And fortunately physionomy will not disappear from our lives.
We imbue faces with meaning.
There's just no emotion and neutral face.
We kind of like to look at faces and we always see something can faces,
even if there's nothing there.
And the actual examples of the book where is not thinking the face that suggests
what kind of emotion the person is feeling.
But we tend to see it,
uh,
the and Burka call it that called the phase,
the most entertaining map in the world.
Um,
first impression,
impression,
surf,
important psychological functions.
We tried to infer the immediate intentions,
uh,
of the others in the situation here and now.
And in many ways,
first impression gives us the illusion that too is kind of,
uh,
can reduce the uncertainty of living quit strangers.
Something that appeared only in the last,
if you imagine human evolution compressed within 24 hours who haven't been
living with strangers only in the last five minutes of the day.
And this is exactly when physio on and we kind of horizons and becomes extremely
popular when you have big industrial migration.
When suddenly places like New York City,
we have to interact with strangers on an everyday basis all the time.
So in conclusion,
we should remember the wisdom of Lichtenberg a first impression,
slammed the smallest possible knowledge,
the greatest possible appearance of it,
and consider someone Weiss walks wisely and do not be misled by irregularities
on the surface.
Thank you.
I have two questions since it seems like these impressions and tend not to be
very reliable or accurate,
what can we do to stop people from relying on the roof?
Well,
I mean,
so there's couple of things.
You're absolutely right.
Then in fact,
I had a four chapters of the book of Medicare on the question of doctorate sin.
They're not reliable when it comes to reading character.
Now I think that the bad news is that you can stop DePaul forming first
impressions.
There's just a lot of my work is that,
and this is the reason I started getting into it,
what is behind it?
So it can just tell people don't do this and people say,
sure,
I'm not going to do it.
But it's not something that you consciously make yourself,
not do it or do it.
So it's a fairly automatic.
The good news is that in fact if you have reliable information about people,
we change our minds.
So you meet somebody if you like a chill teammates,
I mean maybe you didn't like them in the beginning but eventually get to rely on
them because you see what they really are and you get,
and this is fine.
The problem is when you have situations where it's almost like the first
expression of the gatekeepers,
right?
When you don't have a possibility for interactions and that kind of can preclude
a particularly good interaction or a relationship from occurring,
but generally in how it can quickly override this as long as I give you a good
information about what people have done in the past.
Um,
and then my other question is how much do the kind of feature of people
interpreted as say,
trustworthy or untrustworthy?
How does that vary across cultures?
Do we have,
it's a very good question.
So there's not enough cross cultural work.
I mean,
and then again,
uh,
oh,
so it depends what it is is like cross cross off on like cross cultural council.
If you go to Asia in or you go to Japan,
you know and do a study and in China and then in the United saying that's cross
cultural,
but it's not that really a cross cultural,
you need to go to a small scale,
lone industrialized societies and look at this kinds of effects.
What do we know from some of the work we have done is that cultural typicality
matters.
But you can think this is and in addition to this kind of facial futures,
you know,
convey emotional meaning can even even like the emotions might vary in different
cultures.
For example in the United States and many European countries,
the smallest kind of a way of you can approach me,
but in many Asian culture is kind of a sign of submissiveness.
And the people who have a lower social status are more likely to smile and
communicate different things.
And this apparently correlates with,
you know,
how heterogeneous the societies,
because you know,
in the United States a culture where it's basically a culture,
FEMA grants and there's a way to communicate.
So even this can change from culture to culture.
So culture is extremely important.
Thanks.
Hi.
Thanks for coming in today.
Sure.
You write your book.
Um,
I noticed you talked a lot about what people's first impressions are,
but not a lot of like why they're feeling that way.
Um,
you know,
if it's evolutionary or if it's a learned behavior or,
why are women viewed as more trustworthy,
things like that.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's a,
it's a very good question.
I have a,
I have a whole chapter called devolution.
That restore is where I look at what's the bad and quote.
In fact,
some of this evolutionary theories can explain some of the data.
And,
uh,
my reading is not really,
I mean,
a lot of this has to do well.
The men tend to be physically stronger to,
and dominance is about physical strengths for sure.
So there's some kind of biological underpinning,
but you don't need to even see it in the face.
It's actually in the body.
So for example,
there's been a really lousy measure in psychology that people have used 10 use,
10 use.
It's called the width to height ratio,
the width to height ratio,
essentially the ratio of the width of your face to your heightened they days,
the high disc ratio,
the more physically strong care,
but not only that,
but you're more aggressive with the saunas and this kind of stuff.
And it was interesting [inaudible] uh,
the original interpretation that you'd sexually dimorphic various.
It's only matters for men and men have a higher ratio than women.
In fact,
some people look at Carlson thousand and thousands of participants and it turns
out that in fact the correlations between gender and this ratio is 0.05,
so it's practically zero.
So the whole evolutionary Jerry,
you have to Troy and discard it straight from the now and in real interactions.
And the other hand you feel a body and uh,
you know,
body weight,
body hide,
the correlations tend to be between point 30 point 60 and the correlation with
top of body strength and gender,
it's about point 80.
So this accused that easily available.
You don't need to look at the face.
People can tell from the face your weight,
but guess what?
Larger bodies,
comic launch of faces.
So I mean when it comes to the appearance from the face,
I don't see there's much bearing.
That doesn't mean that evolution didn't play a role.
Um,
have you had the only hairless primates that actually makes the detection of
emotion and changes in the skin?
Very easy.
We also only Momma Steph trichromatic vision seeing Keno in the three basic
colors and not all mammals have it.
And this would couple with our best skin face makes it very easy to detect the
blushing and other kinds of things that uh,
sickness and other things that are important.
We also are the only prime met with,
uh,
whites of the eye,
which makes the detection of Phi gay stupid easy.
Uh,
we have the most delegated,
uh,
ice to begin with.
But that generally is true for all primary school if on the ground because
evolutionary,
it's more efficient to scan the environment rather than turning my whole body on
my head just to scan with my ice and I need to scan horizontally and
interesting,
clear from all of the prime.
It started to add your new one with the whites,
which makes detection of Phi Gates very easy.
And I guess it's important because I can attract your attention.
We can communicate from a distance.
So there are lots of things to be said about the importance of communicating cow
emotional and mental states that the link to comparative changes in facial
appearance.
But I don't see much that could be say that in fact your face is sort of a
imprint of your character from evolutionary point of view and any other point of
view.
And a lot of this is learning can emotions.
Like obviously we'll be,
we'll have a relatively constrained meanings of this.
The things that you will learn and they will be important and they would be fine
here and now my argument is,
but don't take this as this is what the person is like.
I was just curious if the mechanisms that we use to I guess,
judge character based on face incorrectly or they actually very useful for some
other tasks and we're just misusing them by,
uh,
by judging character with them?
Or is it just a standalone thing that we shouldn't be using it?
Well,
I think that I'm in perception is amazing.
Come in,
we are right.
You know,
if you look at the prime,
my brain,
more than half of our brain is dedicated to vision.
So we extremely visual creatures and we make very quick,
very quick rapid judgements.
So we usually,
I mean we,
um,
I mean it's funny because in face recognition until five,
six years ago we'll say,
you know,
the,
they're small computer algorithm that can do better than us.
Unfortunately that's a history now.
But this kind of pattern matching task,
we are incredibly good and,
and he can't say,
don't do this.
I mean it's probably useful and essay.
I'm trying to make the argument that in fact,
even first impressions might be useful trying to figure out,
well,
are you kind of now,
you know,
sort of a relaxed mode.
Should they approach you or you kind of disgruntled?
Maybe I should get out of the way and that's okay.
I'm just saying it,
go from there and make a big inferential leap and say,
well,
this guy is just just because they are having a bad day to day.
That's how they are in general in life.
And there's lots of,
in social psychology,
there's something called the fundamental attribution error.
Just discover a teen or a few decades ago in the fundamental attribution error
is that whatever I observing your behavior,
I tend to attribute to 10 your character.
But of course you might just hear the bad day at work in my head.
Uh,
you know,
argument with your roommate or a partner or whatever.
None of this.
I see.
I see your behavior here now and it's kind of a,
especially in western cultures,
the natural inclination is to say,
well,
hold on.
I've seen you in home in this single slice of behavior that this behavior is
representative a few as a person.
And most of the time it's not because they're multiple causes of behavior.
Do we apply these same types of judgment to other types of primates and then
also to other animals,
um,
that we run across.
So is it possible for me to make the ultimate judgment about what a good dog is?
One,
first of all right.
Interesting.
I mean it's actually new to ascension this and a lot of the work on,
I showed you how in the model some dominance,
like the opposite,
just kind of baby faced appearance and has this great a toll just Congo
chlorines and you might have seen him and he's famous for his docs because the
documents kept this instinct.
The first thing they see moving,
they're kind of follow it because they assume it's their mother.
So they will follow him everywhere.
But Lauren's had this interesting paper showing that um,
a lot of mammals,
they're babies have particular coronial futures,
puppies,
kittens,
humans bulging foreheads in all small chins.
And he argued,
and it's not clear that it's actually true,
but he argued that most of the time this automatically triggers this nurture on
Chris Ponds in,
in,
in adults.
And in fact,
a lot of the work in social psychology in this kinds of impressions started from
there.
And uh,
in fact,
um,
uh,
Jay,
Stephen Jay Gould had an interesting,
they sent the evolution cultural evolution of Mickey Mouse,
Mickey Mouse.
If you look over the years she pesky become more and more popular character.
He started to become much more baby faced features and he kind of tracks and
there has been research Lakey in fact people have this stereotypes and say well
this is this doc or is more baby face.
So it's more submissive.
And you had this soul side thinking of on David four lines,
but I'm not sure.
So the stereotypes are there whether they're in fact map into reality this side
or no,
there was nothing in the paper,
but certainly there's is stereotypes that you apply to other nonhuman animals.
Okay.
You mentioned that,
uh,
in some of the studies there was a prefacing statement like,
you know,
think about making a good judgment before you answer.
Are there other sort of de statements that we can use in our daily lives,
especially in situations where maybe we're evaluating somebody for it or things
like that.
This is
a good point.
I mean actually,
uh,
yeah,
this,
we did it in just one study and most of our studies we just say there are no
right or wrong cancer.
We want you to just use your gut response.
But I mean I think that the best way,
if it's an important decision,
it's important to structure the interaction in such a way that whether it's an
interviewer to some structure or anything comes again,
toll of this information.
A great example is,
and I give this in the book,
is a large symphony orchestra until day to see if you look at the symphony,
York's it's mainly guys,
men,
very few women and suddenly have much more women.
What happens suddenly people became less gender prejudice and they said,
let's give it a goal.
No blind traditions.
That's what happened.
They introduce blind tradition.
So if you're the committee and I'm the candidate or whoever in your than the
other candidate,
they don't see us all day.
Here's how we play.
And suddenly you have a good diagnostic input and you have much more women
represented in symphony orchestra.
But this is like,
it's just the thing could,
psychological bias gets sloughed that most people are bigots.
Most people want to do the right thing.
Most people,
not everybody.
But what happens is that the mice are very subtle and often what you're
observing,
the world disparity,
ambiguous.
It's not clear cut.
I mean everybody who comes to a great symphony orchestra to audition,
they all great musicians to begin with.
So it's very hard to say all this guy's really good.
And I mean it's all a take a pool of candidates to put his to say,
oh this,
this is the pallof reject easier,
right?
But then you suddenly have a third way.
Everybody's pretty good.
And then this is where biases come in.
You know,
if you just,
they can shape who not you one way or another,
and then you ended up with a particular decision.
And if people don't think they're doing something wrong as far as the thinking
they're doing the right thing,
they're doing their best.
But often we are not aware of these biases and particularly in first impressions
because you can talk about trace,
you can talk about gender,
you can talk about sexual orientation.
These are things that we've been talking for many decades.
Doesn't mean that uh,
we've gotten much better in handling kid.
But at least there's some kind of explicit awareness for things that you don't
even talk.
It's just happens.
And if you don't,
um,
take big cautionary measures is going to influence you.
So I mean it's just very much depends when length of your graduate students,
I hate interviews cause unstructured interviews kept zero utility weld and then
they do the correlations between future success is point then that is basically
percent of the variance.
Why do we interview people?
I mean it's like it should know where they want this person based.
In this particular case,
you have lots of evidence for past performance and that should be enough to make
up your decision.
Now issue,
we just put too much faith.
We all,
the way these impressions,
we overweight in interviews or not even,
it's not just the sink an image.
You interact with a person for 30 minutes,
30 minutes is still a very little time.
And you know,
like if you're shy,
maybe wouldn't do so well because the anxiety provoking situation.
So it's just,
but it's very hard to get rid of this.
We as people think they know it,
they saw it.
I mean the kind of,
it feels fright.
But if you look closely at the evidence,
well,
interviews are not very good.
I mean,
take letters of reference.
They're much better,
not perfect.
Why?
Because they summarize samples of observations over a longer time.
It's not my impression.
A few within 30 minutes of informal discussion.
Right?
So it's,
if it's an important decision,
you should just try to look for good,
reliable evidence that is indicative of whatever you're trying to achieve in the
particular situation.
Thank you.
You're welcome.